hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and I
wish out you welcome two reasons to see
well we give you reasons to see gas too
so try to have fun otherwise reason to
see number one Colonel stars and stripes
now before we get into this review I I
already know how I feel and I already
know how these to feel and stick around
folks it's gonna get intense today we're
gonna get into it debate know the digit
if you call reasons to see this should
be called reasons [ __ ] with each other
that was the best I got
let's talk about Colonel stars and
stripes Jim Carrey talk [ __ ] on this
movie right guys and honestly Megyn
talks [ __ ] necessarily just said he
couldn't support it because of you know
saying hey well we're gonna be technical
about in short anyway come on say it's a
crappy movie he just said he couldn't
say no I get it yeah we're gonna be
technical about it totally God okay so
basically technically technically it's
not technical if you aren't you a Jerry
about vocabulary he can last hours if
you guys want to see that Dec got her
next a very different thing see what I
mean Jim Carrey I really enjoyed his
performance he wasn't hilarious he
wasn't you know mr. funny guy but he was
still pretty [ __ ] cool he was a
badass I thought it was a total badass
well that's what I appreciate about him
in this movie because I feel about Jim
Carrey a similar way I feel about Adam
Sandler except I like Jim Carrey much
better than that I'm Sandler I really
appreciated him in this movie because
he's fully committed to a character he's
not just Jim Carrey mugging he is
actually being a character and that was
so refreshing to me you you compared Jim
Carrey to have him salmon only in the
sense that there are two guys who do
lots of broad comedies and then every
time I watch those broad comedies I'm
like it's very apparent you are playing
you because
liar liar yes have you seen Dumb and
Dumber have you seen the Masel Ace
Ventura they are different caliber you
could take Jim Carrey's performance as
his character for his own merits you're
not thinking oh this is Jim Carrey the
character of sharing the screen and
elevating those scenes and honestly I
thought because he backed so much heavy
[ __ ] on this movie I thought he it would
be so distracting watching him but it
wasn't he did a great job really embody
the role reason two seat number two the
action I liked the action it was the
reaction yeah that makes a lot of sense
I loved the action in this film when
when the first action scene came on the
screen I was like yes this is still
badass I really enjoyed it and it was
fantastic some really cool action a
little bit more over the top than before
but that's what I liked about it they
took it to a whole new level there are
definitely some really cool action
scenes that and they're all different
there are some unique you know ways in
which the characters fight each other
because they all are these eccentric
superhero you know types and stuff like
that that I still think the action the
first one was more interesting to watch
well let's let's save the negative song
for a little later huh later on when it
gets intense reason is scene number
three the other superheroes I like the
other superheroes I thought they had
interesting name yeah I would love to do
things tonight [ __ ] probably my
favorite element of this movie is all
the different heroes and villains that
come in all the different designs and
names and even the actors who play them
yell like Donald Faison who is from like
clueless and scrubs and stuff like I
thought he was a lot of fun to watch
those characters add a lot of color to
this world and it's one of the most
interesting things because that's what
makes this movie bigger than the first
one is that now there are tons of heroes
and tons of villains and stuff like yeah
you know not just the other superheroes
I thought they're having super villains
was cuz some of the super villains
remember more interesting at times than
the super heroes I thought it made it
that much bigger that much cooler was
awesome to see like wow because of
kick-ass look what's
I think it was cool how this movie had
more of a a way like an Avengers feel
and that whole like teaming up kind of
wet idea even though of course it's not
like few ventures at all but I would
have to disagree with you this is on the
same level as Joss Whedon's movie this
is the event well this is what the
Avenger should have been that is an
interesting point though because whereas
the first kick-ass is a little more
trying to be grounded in a gritty
version of the real world this one is a
bit more of a heightened superhero movie
that felt more like a superhero film to
me and we will save the talk for later
when it gets intense heads are gonna be
flying penises are gonna be in the air
so Jessie your guys's got a penis smart
decisions here we go people
picture a real what the [ __ ] you spoke
over the voice-over part okay what
decisions here we go people
hick girl I would just like to say
whatever happens happens but I we will
still be friends by the end of this
Chloe grace Moretz hmm oh she is not a
teen this is a problem for me it makes
the movie a little creepy a title I to
you I really liked her performance a lot
I thought she was the best actress in
this film I thought it was so cool that
they were able to capture both her
humanity female side and at the same
time you know still maker of badass I
never for one second data that this girl
can still do what she does yeah no I'm
on board with you on that you know it's
like I can I still believed her as the
ass-kicking little girl that she is okay
a little more grown-up okay the the word
I feel describes this movie is just
intermittent because I do like elements
of her performance in this movie and as
the movie goes on later into the movie I
started to to genuinely like what she
was doing so what
didn't you like Jerry well I mean the
whole first half-hour of this movie I
was sitting here going this is all
posturing like it feels like it's trying
to be kicked out it feels like some dude
dressed up in a kick-ass costume and
trying to do it the movie itself and
that includes her is like I didn't start
buying her as a character until they
really splintered her storyline off I
didn't get that vibe I thought they were
I thought they were keeping up they're
trying to make it a little bit fresh and
by making it a little bit darker and
stuff and it had more of a grit to me
from the very beginning you know I'm
dealing with that that element but
bouncing like I just didn't really feel
I didn't think they were trying to copy
kick-ass at all I thought it was just
the continuation and the director
understood the tongue I think you really
understood hit girl too because hit girl
was like they made her the main
character essentially she's the core of
this film like the most I could tell you
is this guy's this movie's called
kick-ass and how it was Hit Girl
well she kicks ass I felt like her
character arc was kind of chop chop II
like I understand what they were trying
to go for but I felt forced to me I felt
like it was very like oh this is a good
idea let's stick this in the movie that
was really distracting for me was I was
like it seems like it's trying too hard
and that's why I couldn't really buy it
I didn't get that at all she in the
movie she learns to embrace her feminine
side and it it made sense how she
learned to embrace her feminine side
while also embracing who she is a part
of who she grew up as a child and being
taught her whole life was to pretty much
be a badass and that and so that is who
she is is she is Hit Girl those ideas
are good but I do agree with Michelle
it's like a lot of stuff especially
toward the beginning in the first half
of the movie felt forced to me well
here's what I can tell you I did not
feel that way you felt differently
that's why it's a split decision and I
cannot change your feelings what
decision number two it kicks ass I
thought this film was totally badass I
thought it was funny as [ __ ] i thought
the action was really cool i disagree so
much i'm jerry said about a hit girl
every time she said one of her lines i
thought Chloe grace Moretz did it like
perfectly and I did
me crack up a lot and I thought when she
got like her revenge at moments that was
like oh like hell yeah that's kick-ass
somebody so much in this way was this
kicks ass that was me a lot of the time
but I kicked ass intermittently because
there are some stuff that was really
cool I was like whoa I remember watching
a movie and saying that stuff and
remember some stuff that was really
funny but like on the whole I was it's
like hey it was okay and I feel like
damn that was a really cool ass movie at
the end like I did that first one I
thought it was way cooler I thought the
emotional stuff was even darker and you
get more into the the actual emotional
aspects of it all like it gets really
dark in this film see for some reason
the whole time watching it and maybe
it's just a product of the fact that
they have more stories going on and
stuff like that a lot of that emotional
depths and stuffs like that felt less
deep than the first movie just because
it was like okay here's four sentences
about this thing now we got to move on
so it's like I get that the characters
go those places but I didn't really feel
it a whole lot but the whole point
though is to entertain you and I thought
this was an entertaining film well one
of the things that I really felt was
that it was dragging and that's where it
lost me on an attainment factor because
I felt like things were dragged out and
I was kind of like bored I was like okay
when is this thing gonna happen like did
they forget about this like there are
times when I was like thinking about
wanting to go on my phone during the
movie and I really have that feeling Jay
if you ever do that with me I swear to
God I will like vomit on you then that's
the thing it's like it's in term in
because I thought that alleyway fight
scene was way cool and Hit Girl was
sufficiently bad as in that scene the
truck sequence was pretty cool when
she's on top of the truck and she's
trying to get kick-ass back inside but
even with the super villain like that
that russian chick was cool and and Jim
Carrey was [ __ ] : why did you hate the
Russian [ __ ] there is I mean there is
definitely some badass stuff and the end
and the end the final in the finale I
thought was a cool fight too yeah no it
was a cool fight I'm not saying it's
devoid of being cool at all I'm just
saying that not
thing felt natural to me like there was
some fights that I thought were super
cool and inventive and then there other
fights where you know I was just like
you're just kind of having a fight and
whatever you know where oh I don't
remember this specific moment but I
remember there was one fight where I
literally was like we didn't even need
to have this fight I was saying like the
dark emotional stuff was cool because
when the action scenes finally came up
there was a more meaning binding like
when that finale a lot of stuff happens
with kick-ass is character and hate
girl's character where it's like I can
feel why they're fighting and I get me I
felt that effect of like yeah this is
what they're meant to do and this and
this is like what's supposed to happen
yeah yeah where they choose to take the
story is really cool in those senses but
the problem is the way those moments
played out yeah didn't really grab me
that much worse like the first kick-ass
was I saw the trailer it was like oh
this looks like fun and then I saw it
and it was much darker and more
subversive than I thought it would be
this movie doesn't really achieve that
for me it's like here's a few sentences
about this thing we're destined to do I
think that one scene in the first
kick-ass with Big Daddy taking down
those people in that warehouse is a much
more kick-ass than the whole of kick-ass
2 well I think Matthew Vaughn is a
stronger director I just kind of like
this there's low medium high and very
high and kick-ass one is very high and
to me kick-ass 2 at least falls in
medium or high kick-ass 2 to me kind of
becomes the movie that kick-ass one did
such a good job of not being like it
it's almost basically just a superhero
movie except you get that sort of ragtag
we're just people thing it's more
heightened this time to the point where
they're kind of superheroes and they're
kind of superhuman and then that sort of
real-world thing it's like they keep
saying this isn't a comic book and I
felt like they kept shoving that one in
there to make things seem real and it
was like but you're not doing much about
but it's not real I'll give you that it
feels see that's what I mean I thought
it was cheesy and stuff like that I
didn't it was like these people are
taking it seriously but it with the
flaws I thought they were cheesy flaws
and I was okay with them I just honestly
thought it was a really worthy sequel
because I felt like it was just picking
up from where we left off at and
I really enjoyed it but a decision
number three kick ass look Aaron
taylor-johnson dude Wow
you got cut he did can't you go you got
you what whoa you you took your [ __ ]
seriously on this one homie kindly
worked his glutes to his hair was too
much but with Aaron taylor-johnson
I really liked him in this film you know
he way I didn't I wasn't as invested in
him as I was in the first one because
this moment you get more invest in a hit
girls story in this particular film like
he's called a kick-ass and it's with
kick-ass one by the end of it no one
really thought of kick-ass because he
wasn't that kick-ass by the end of the
movie but in this one he is like he
kicks ass in this movie I feel the same
way about him as I did about Chloe
Moretz which is a bummer to me because
it's like in the first half or so of
this movie he just was kind of a blank
character to me and and even his
narration felt sort of overly peppy and
forced in it it was like you're trying
to recapture I probably this movie is
trying to recapture a lot of the essence
this is the first one but it just didn't
succeed a lot of the time and I did
eventually end up liking him in that
third act area where he finally becomes
a character for real I was really bored
of him up and to the point the last act
I was like the first kick-ass he has a
lot of personality and he he has you
know you get this balance of he's a high
school teenager but he's also trying to
be a superhero and he's this plucky
scrawny dude with a lot of heart and in
this one they just don't make him a
character for a lot of the movie he's a
sort of a cipher to introduce us to all
these other superheroes and to get us
into the group space and you know
occasionally I totally disagree he he's
older now he has a much more darker
personality inside of him that they have
may has more that ank's with his dad
going on he would be more serious I was
kind of wondering where it is this angst
with your dad come from he was going
through his bedroom yeah it was like
really like he got really dramatic I
don't know where because dad for to me
that's what it seemed like I was like
whoa whoa whoa it's coming cuz they
share a scene where he's like I'm
worried about your son you're not doing
drugs or anything he's like no and he's
like that's all I gotta hear buddy and
then he goes
when the very next scene he's like I've
found your kick-ass [ __ ] he's like I'm
leaving the house and I'm like yeah
where's the creek because his dad didn't
wanted to be kick-ass anymore you have
to be on his own in order to be kick-ass
yeah I know but I felt like they could
have if they wanted that to be a heavy
dramatic moment they could have given it
a heavier traumatic package anyway when
it was like this tension out of just got
out of hand out of nowhere there was no
like building tension with the father
character the second that he's then set
next scene he's blowing up in his dad's
face being like overdramatic yeah I just
thought it was like very entertaining
like there I felt the commentary of the
writers like but you said it was like
dark and emotional it has dark and
emotional stuff but I don't find it too
heavy I don't I didn't think it was a
heavy impact I thought it was just
enough to make the other stuff cooler
what decision number four the
[ __ ]
I did like homeboy for the most part I
liked him a time I loved how they
changed up his character a lot he had
some of the funniest moments the dude I
liked him way more in this one that I
did in the last one I thought he made a
great villain he was like he's funny as
hell he was funny but you're supposed to
be a joke in a way though yeah and I
kind of got bored of his character too
and I kind of feel like it's some points
to off the movie they kind of like put
him way too far in the background where
it's like you're thinking okay one [ __ ]
gonna happen with the mode [ __ ] I'm
waiting for this [ __ ] that could
pop up somewhere what are you talking
about the [ __ ] does pop up
aligns book and took a while for the
climax to reach to get to that point
that's what she said the supervillains
are more interesting by default than the
heroes are and so when he shows up he
did bring me a lot more sort of at least
fun interesting stuff to watch and him
and John that was each other yeah
off each other like well I like them
together
Brian's Consensus kick ass to kick so
much ass and it's the reason to see kick
ass to kick ass to kick so much ass and
that's the reason to see kick ass - yeah
you know I I disagree with these two
dumbasses over here I thought it was a
total blast had a great time even when
it was bad it was entertaining I really
I would just entertained the whole time
Sherri's consensus there are a few
reasons to see kick ass - there are a
few reasons to see kick ass - there's
some stuff that works about it it's to
me it's largely just sort of an uneven
intermittent film like there's elements
of everything that works at some point
but a few things ever totally worked for
me so it's okay I guess Michels
consensus there are some reasons to see
kick ass - there are some reasons to see
kick ass - I think that despite its
flaws it's still worth going to see if
you really liked the original it's not
gonna ruin the that's what I'm not the
original but the first one it's not
gonna ruin the first one for you but you
might just not be completely satisfied
the [ __ ] wasn't as intense as I thought
it was going to be damn it people kids
were gonna intense for one second
alright guys let's check it out a review
for kick-ass to watch it go ahead score
that comment box below and tell me who's
celebrity whose ass would you kick and
when you done with that once you come
over here click it to click this little
button to see more episodes of reason to
secede and if you want to go ahead and
follow us on Twitter you can click the
link right here and if you want to like
us on Facebook you can click the link
right here and last but not least if you
want to get updated every time a new
review of our video is out subscribe
chick ass
ha kidney kidney no kick knee kick knee
yeah you know they say sweep the leg and
Karate Kid but I say kick knee hey
that's a pretty horrible place to kick
something yeah if you've ever seen max
remover specially in the back of the
knee
yeah we're well the back of the knee
wouldn't be as bad because you actually
Bend but yeah she's like what if you
like bend it backwards like yeah yeah
kick knee when you castrate and then you
can you can rip some tendons there
that's true I'm pretty sure if you were
able to do it backwards you can still do
the same thing you can I'm just saying
that backwards I know but the point of
the conversation was that the front of
it would hurt more than the back I had
all this energy ready to fight with you
guys and none of you got to do it with
me now what am I supposed to do with it
masturbate it's not going to work
you